what is up guys my name is Archana and
welcome to episode 14 of 3d game
programming in Java now we are going to
be doing mouths movement today because
you guys said that you would like that
I'll prove it to you guys don't believe
that I am probably do I mean who wants
jumping when you when you can have mouse
movement like come on oh yeah mouse
movement mouse movement mouse movement
mouse movement mouse movement I'm not
even going to go to the next page mouse
movement okay so this is sort of gonna
be like a long test Oriole I think
because I really feel that I need to
explain how this works
so let's just check out what we had last
time so um we had you know we have to
use the arrow keys to move around and
basically all we're going to going to
accomplish today to do today is change
sort of the controls from being the
arrow keys to rotate to being the mouse
to rotate and yeah so let's just let's
dive in real quick this is gonna be
quite complicated it's gonna be fun
basically this one that's what I'm
trying to say okay so first thing I sort
of want to introduce here is the fact
that programming is about 90 percent
about the the logic of it so it's 90
percent of working out what you need to
do what you need to write and ten
percent actually working out how to
write it or to code it you know actually
writing it so just remember that that
the hardest part in programming ninety
percent is unless my opinion of course
but it is to actually work out what it
is exactly that you need to do okay so
what does he definitely need to do at
this point now on first glance you know
you might just say oh no it's okay all
we have to do here is open up - I'm
sorry what we have to do here is just
make it so that when the mouse moves you
know right you move right when the mouse
moves let you move left okay that's not
quite exactly what we want to do though
what we want in a detailed description
is to basically note down at the current
position of the mouse on the screen and
then say okay well if the
moves to the right so in other words if
the exposition if the horizontal
coordinate of the mouse increases then
you need to move right you need to
rotate right until you stop because when
you stop you want to stop rotating okay
so if the if the coordinate doesn't
change don't rotate but then if you have
to move left you know say okay if we
move if the mouse coordinate dick if the
x-coordinate of the mouse decreases so
phenomena gets smaller then rotate left
because that's what we need to do but
after every because we could just set
like a point of origin say here and say
okay well if the mouse is on this side
of the screen go left and the mouse is
on that side of the screen go right but
no because as soon as the mouse stops we
need to make this this current
coordinate the new origin of it so that
if we move left from that point it will
move left not if we move left from this
point so we need to need to update that
origin point every time we move the
mouse and the way we're gonna do this
actually work this out yesterday it's
pretty simple it's not hard it's might
be hard to understand first but when you
finally understand it you'll be like oh
how did I not get that earlier of course
so let's take a look at this okay so
first thing let's we've sort of got our
keyboard and our focus lost stuff worked
out here let's go up to mouse moved now
there's two there's mouse dragged
there's mouse move there's mouth played
Mouse answered Mouse exited don't worry
about this stuff we don't actually need
that at the moment probably won't even
use that Mouse anted is when it enters a
particular component exited is one and
exits a particular component in your
friend don't worry about that clicked is
obviously when you click the mouse so in
other words we use this to actually
shoot our gun later on when we have a
gun a home mouse drag is when you click
and drag okay now smooth is when you
don't click and drag when you just move
the mouse like this like I am right now
so in other words we don't want to click
and drag to move right we just want to
move the mouse and then it should it
should rotate so let's go ahead and and
start coding right over here okay so the
way I'm gonna do this is I'm actually
going to make two variables up here I'm
gonna make a variable called
and we have to make it static
because we okay static means that it can
be accessible through another class
without having to actually create that
object so instead of going so in other
words I'll explain this later don't
worry I'll keep that for later because
it'll be easier to explain in about five
minutes once we finish this okay so
public static int we want an integer
we'll just call it
I don't know Mouse X so this will be the
mouse coordinate and we want to assign
it to anything yet this will be the
x-coordinate of the mouse and right now
even though we're not going to use the
y-coordinate so now I want to set it up
anyway so a public static int Mouse Y
right so you know what that is y is you
know the vertical X is horizontal it's
pretty simple okay and over here we
actually have to assign it to something
so let's go ahead and say okay well
Mouse X is going to we're going to
assign it to a and a is our Mouse event
object dot get X okay now if you saw
that there were two on-screen there was
the get X and the get X on-screen now
get X is relative to the actual frame
okay so in other words if we run this if
we run this that is zero zero that is
eight hundred six hundred all right
because that's the size of our window
however get X on screen would mean that
this is zero zero and this is 1920 by
1080 okay because that's all of the
things so in other words this would be
something like I don't know like 400 by
okay I'm really bad at this unless you
said that's half of it so about eight
hundred by four hundred of
so in other words we don't want it to do
that we wanted to set we wanted to to
grab the coordinates of the actual of
the frame not of the actual screen so
that's the difference between those two
in case you guys were wondering and all
do the same thing for y you get Y so
that's going to return the vertical Y
position of the event relative to the
source component I could just read this
actually and this is going to return the
absolute vertical Y position of the
event that's in relation order to say
here this is relative to the
we'll frame this is a relative to the
actual monitor you're using the national
screen using okay so that is setup and
that's pretty much all we need to do in
this method so sorry in this class so
all we're doing here is we're just
saying okay well let's create two
variables and let's assign those
variables to the current location sorry
to the yet to the current position of
the mouse the horizontal position and
the vertical position that is all we're
doing okay what are we up to seven
minutes not bad not bad
okay you guys said that you loved the
long tutorials that's what she said I
know I read the comments all you guys
seem to uh seem to pick up on that I'm
good I'm glad you guys can pick up on
that but um yeah sir this will be long I
don't know a previous best with 33
minutes I think 30 32 minutes I think
that's how that's how I record let's see
if we can made it hopefully not this
shouldn't be that long to explain okay
so let's let's just test that real quick
because if you know me I love testing
stuff so system dot out dot print line
and let's just go ahead and print X
right and then what okay so here we go
let's just let's deal with this if we
didn't make it static I really want to
explain static cuz I feel I need to so
if we didn't make it static it gets out
of italics to tell you that then what we
need to do is way okay if we want to
actually use that variable let's just
drag it let's just make this a line here
so that we can see both screens what we
would have to do in order to access this
is we would have to make an object of
the input handler class so in other
words you know out on a private input
handler private input handler input
handler whatever you name the object
notices we'd have to create the object
what am i doing
we have to create the objects or input
handler equals new input let's just copy
and paste that and come in here and
change that to a big guy and then we'd
have to go ahead and say
if we wanted to use that variable where
every NGO input handler dot Mouse X and
that's that's the fun I'm gonna have to
all I have to not answer that
I'm also an alts picks it up that's good
and we have to use that okay we have to
use that variable that way now that's
not going to work for us and no method
that's not that's actually not gonna
work for us and I can set that equal to
zero to make it to make it work that's
not gonna work for us okay I actually
tried this and also that's that's just
unnecessary just that doing doing that
whole process like look we've got
throughout this whole new thing we've
got we have to initialize we have to
create the object we have to create the
object we have to initialize the object
you know it's just stupid because all we
have to do is all we want to do is
access that variable it's not really a
method we're accessing just a variable
so if we put static here then what we
can do is mm hmm let's see here
all we have to do here is just go ahead
and actually type the name of the class
so input handler as you can see with a
big eye because we're actually referring
directly to the class dot now for x
equals I don't know zero okay and that
will work fine so in other words well
what we can do here to sort of test that
test what we've done is go ahead and say
plus input handler adult Mouse X plus
and let's also print that why I'm
leaving a space here so the so that the
two things aren't you know close
together so they have a space in between
plus input handler dot Mouse wife and
let's run that and display our console
okay so as you can see what it's
displaying here is you can see the
x-coordinate and the y-coordinate of the
mouse and you can see how that's
changing every time we'll every time I
move the mouse and it's printing
correctly you know I said 800 by 600
yeah that's right okay so it's
completely it's actually doing that
because we extended it by 10 pixels if
you remember we plot we added 10 to this
because of that blinking thing that
window would actually don't really need
to use what is it
dimensions but it doesn't matter when we
might need to in the future I'll keep it
like that but yeah that's why I actually
goes to uh you know 810 by 610 but yeah
so that's all working our coordinate
system is working it is getting the the
coordinates of the mouse in real time so
that's awesome that is our first step in
completing our mouse movement let's say
let's go ahead and check the let's go
ahead and check the the second step and
the second step here I don't actually
have a it it sounds like I've got like a
list in front of me and I'm just looking
at it I don't I actually don't
so um I'm actually I'm just I'm looking
inside my head right now as to what we
need to do next and what we need to do
next is actually write a sort of
updating thing so it sounds confusing
it's not confusing at all okay so I
think of it this way right we've let's
just delete this we've we've got our
x-coordinate and we've got our
y-coordinate so now what we need to do
is we need to measure it for change so
we need to say okay well as as you can
see that's sort of our I don't know that
right there is our like 300 on the X
sorry um North round 400 that's the
middle 400 of the X and now if we go
left we need to measure if that number
has changed so how do we record that
number and record you know if it's
change not and it's actually pretty
simple first thing I want to do is
create two integers I'll make it private
actually now I'll put it under here will
put it under here so private integer int
we'll call it let's call it new X and
then we'll and then we'll make another
one for the for the Y so private int new
Y and we'll actually
than both equal to zero okay let's calm
down into here and just under frames
plus plus go ahead and say okay
nu X we'll set that equal to our actual
mouse thing so input handle adult Mouse
X okay awesome
so now we've assigned we've s at we've
assigned this variable to be equal to
whatever the mouse position digital
whatever the mouse coordinate is at the
moment and now we're going to sort of do
like a series of things here what we're
going to do is we're going to say okay
so if a series of if statements if our
new X is equal sorry is greater than our
input Handler dot mouse X then um let's
just print that we're going right so
system dot out dot print line right
figure to this right okay and if it's
the opposite so in other words if new X
is less oh sorry what am i doing hang on
old X okay so I'll explain this in a
minute um it's refusing me okay hold X
what do I do
okay well I mean dealing with the X at
the moment not thinking as far as like
11 I am I go up like an hour ago
okay so if our new X is less than old X
then we're going left so and I'll
explain how this works in a minute
I just wanna actually write the card
first left okay and finally if our new X
is equal to our old X then print that we
are still because we're not moving
so let's just print still and finally at
the end of this we actually need to set
our old X equal to our new X so that we
get the current coordinate of it and
this is basically how it's gonna work
okay
so the way that this works let's just
actually test it real quick awesome it
works so if you look at the bottom thing
and you see that if I start moving it
right it'll say right as soon as I stop
it's gonna say still if I start moving
it left one side left and soon as I
solve is going to stay still
it's going to say still not stay still
say still okay so the way that this
works is it says okay well first of all
oh and and the important thing is that
this code is in a while loop this is in
the while it's running loop so it's
constantly getting updated and of course
in Java it gets updated in the in the
order that it's written in so it's doing
this first and it's doing this and stone
test and it's sewing this and it's doing
this okay so let's take a look at this
real quick so at the moment the first
time we run it old X is equal to zero so
it was new X but it's okay because we
said we said actually we probably wiped
that out doesn't matter we are we set we
set new X equal to input handle up Mouse
X so let's take it let's take just a
scenario here real quick let's just say
that X at the moment is equal to 400
right and old X of course is equal to
zero because that's we haven't actually
given it a value apart from zero yet
that's what we was that's what we've
assigned to it at the moment so if a new
X is greater than all decks so new X at
the moment is we've said that it's 400
and old X is zero right so it is greater
let's print right but see what happens
is that when this gets updated and it
comes down to here we set old X to equal
whatever new X is right so now we've
said okay well it's 400 so new X is 400
so set old X equal to 400 so now they're
both equal to 400 right and now it goes
down and it says and it gets another
coordinate okay if we haven't moved and
and we still are equal to 400 if the
mouse X variable is still
to 400 then it's gonna skip this because
that's not true that's not true oh this
is true it is equal to the same they're
both equal to 400 so print still and now
update it so they're both 400 again
let's go up to the top and do it again
nu X we get it now it's 500 okay
is nu X greater than old X an old X is
still 400 so yes it is greater so let's
print right go down which this is not
true this is not true and now they're
both equal to 500 and you get it if you
go back and we we say okay nu X we've
now moved left so let's get Ben let's
get the mouse x-coordinate again
oh it's equal to 400 okay that's not
true 400 is less than 500 so print left
and then update it so they're both equal
to 400 again so that's the way that this
sort of updating thing works and it's
it's pretty it's pretty it's a pretty
clever idea that I thought of uh-huh and
it is again actually I just want to have
a quick disclaimer here real quick this
whole series okay this isn't about
teaching you guys how to do how to do
this this game stuff the most efficient
way we're not doing it the best way
because they probably is a better way to
actually do mouse movement than this
we're not doing it the best way we're
doing it the way that I'm doing it okay
the way that I know how to do it then I
know how to do this okay
so we're doing it my way that's how it's
tell us rolling so if you guys someone
says dude that's not the best way to do
it this is the best way to do it I don't
care okay this is the way I'm doing it
if you have any suggestions of course
live it all I'll take that into
consideration and I'll say if it's
better anyway let's get back to this um
so we've sort of worked this out now you
can see that it's going right and it's
going a left and basically what mouse
movement you know we've we figured out
how to have this rolls so let's move on
to the next step which is actually
assigning it to this okay so first thing
I want to do is I want to actually wipe
out these two variables so let's go
actually let's go into game first
we don't need controls for this now
because we've changed it to the mouse so
let's just wipe that out and we'll have
to wipe this out of course and let's go
into tick and we'll have to wipe out
bullying turn left and balloon turn
right okay so there we go we've and
don't worry about this we'll keep this
right there because um we'll create some
new balloons for it so let's let's do
that whole static thing again let's go
ahead and say and we'll make sure you do
it off the top make sure you don't do it
in the take method do it in the actual
class so public static again because we
want to access it from a different class
without having to initialize the object
public static bullying the turn left
so we'll just call we're called the same
for this sake we'll set that equal to
false because when we start the game we
don't want it to start turning left okay
we want to just to say still and we'll
do the same thing for this public static
bullying turn right
hey well is also equal to false okay
and that is pretty much all we need to
do in this class arm we've set it so
that okay if that equals true then it's
going to start rotating left if that
equals if that equals true if that
equals false is not going to going to do
that obviously but if that equals false
and that sorry that equals true Liam's
gonna start rotating right okay so back
in the display class what we didn't do
now is sort of said okay there's gonna
go right so now let's set right equal to
true right just go ahead and say
controller dot turn right equals true
let's set it equal to true because
that's what that's what's happening and
we'll do the same thing for here so
controller dot turn left is equal to
what am i doing true sorry if it's so if
it is turning right if it's increasing
then turn right equal to true so turn
left equals true but this is the
important thing when it is still we
wanted that we want to completely stop
everything obviously so what we need to
do is we need to say controller dot turn
left and and we're need to set that
equal to false and controller turn right
when it also set equal to false right so
it can if it's still then it's not
rotating guess let's test this out real
quick and look at that we have rotation
with the mouse movement look at that
amazing it
okay so we've got a few issues here but
for the main part it works and you can
see in that you can see in the console
here as well it's printing which way
it's going which is awesome which way
we're out heading and if it's still on
stuff like that so yeah that's awesome
about 22 minutes shorter than I expected
but uh it's okay we're not done yet
um I guess let's let's close this we've
got a few problems actually with it okay
there's a few not really issues but
there's sort of three problems that
basically stop this from being a final
version of the mouse movement the first
thing is the pointer on the screen you
don't want this pointer on the screen
right you wanted to not exist basically
so we need to remove this this pointer
second thing is we need to stop the
mouse from getting out of the screen we
need to say that okay if it gets to here
let's have it
appear over here okay so that it sort of
loops the screen same with up and down
we're actually going to do that today
because there's just not enough time but
well we might do that next look next to
the next tutorial next episode and the
third issue we have at the moment is
that no matter how fast we move it it's
not actually gonna snow actually gonna
move that fast it's going to move the
same speed if we move it this fast or if
we move it this fast okay so it's not
actually gonna change it's actually
gonna change speed so we need to measure
the speed and we also won't do that
today so yeah so basically what we need
to do in the end product in the final
product is detect how fast the mouse is
moving and multiply that by the speed of
our rotate the speed of our rotation
which is right here right so our
rotation speed needs to be dependent of
how fast the mouse actually moves so
that's the other thing we have to do um
but let's just go ahead right here and
start on something this mouse pointer
because that's probably the biggest
problem at the moment okay so yeah let's
close that and get into this get onto
this get into this let's trace that
okay so Buffett we're gonna use our
Buffett image again where you actually
use that book and we're gonna make a new
one we're gonna call it cursor alright
because that's our mouse pointer that's
what's called and we're gonna go ahead
and say new Buffett image and 16 but
just copy down what I'm doing 16 16 this
dimensions of the emails and buffered
image dot type we need are a RGB right
there and now it's a bit
RGBA components and it's packed into
integer pixels that's what we need for
our mouse and let's make a new cursor
objects we're just going to call this
blank I guess because it's invisible and
we're gonna set that equal to toolkit
toolkit dot get default toolkit and dog
create custom cursor and we're gonna go
ahead and set it equal to cursor and
we're gonna go ahead and say new point
zero zero and we're gonna just I don't
know called blank and there we go
I guess so first thing when you do is
import Gaza and same point we need to do
is same point haha second thing we need
to do is import our point class I guess
now we've got these two important and
the last thing we need to do so we've
actually we're actually created the
blind curves and now we actually have to
set the codes they equal to that and
that's pretty easy we just go frame dot
get content get content pain content
pain dot set cursor and we set that to
blank and that is it ladies and
gentlemen let's check those tests out we
have no cursor and we if we actually
drag off we do applicator so that is
working correctly so now we have
achieved mouse movement congratulations
and I'm happy that we did this because
this was
this is relatively easy to do and you
can see that this still works actually
we can probably I'll just leave it there
for all sorts of purposes because I like
sort of knowing what's happening and it
and if it doesn't work then we can
diagnose it properly okay fantastic so
that is that's mouse movement the only
thing is again it does go off the screen
and we don't want it to go off the
screen we wanted to if we just drag it
like this infinitely we wanted to keep
rotating all right and we don't want the
mouse to go off the screen we want to
basically say that once this is focused
once this is focused don't actually get
out of the screen keep looping the mouse
like that and we'll we'll talk about
that next time
and the other thing that well okay so
yeah we're come for coming to a fork in
the road here what I would personally
like to do next lesson next next next
next episode next to it tutorial what I
would like to do in episode 15 is
continuing this mouse thing this mouse
stuff so that we actually get the speed
of the mouse working properly and and
this looping thing working properly okay
that's my personal recommendation and
that's personally what I want to do and
I think that that would be best because
because I would like to sort of do Mouse
from start to finish like in one sort of
in in consecutive episodes instead of
having to return to this like 10
episodes later or whatever two or even
two episodes later so that's what I
would like to do but if you guys really
want to do jumping or and no I can't I
don't simply didn't I simply do not have
enough time to do two things in one
tutorial I mean this is 28 minutes 30
seconds and to prepare for this tutorial
that took a while as well because I
actually had to work out how I was gonna
do a mouse movement okay so yeah I can't
do two things in one in one episode so
we could either do jumping I guess we
could do textures or we could actually
finish this mouse movement stuff which I
would prefer to do okay so head on over
to my channel and write down what you
guys want to do again there'll be a
little thing saying episode 15 mount
advanced mouse move
or whatever just write what you want to
do there and I personally recommend that
we continue this math stuff because I
really want to sort of finish that right
and then we might even move on to why
we're not going to do why Mouse yet
because I really want to finish X Mouse
of course so that is what we need to do
okay so that's pretty much it a few
other things again um I had a few people
telling me that I was stealing not just
courage from his his lot him dare
challenge thing I actually said that
that I would be I'd be using some of the
stuff that not could not that not
actually created which is like oval that
he demonstrated like this at this
rendering stuff for those of you think
I'm just directly copying from knotch he
didn't do mouse movement and you're
looking at mouse movement right now so
no I'm not actually I'm not actually
directly copying everything that notch
is not she's doing it that not showed in
his live stream I am using some of the
techniques because I didn't know of them
before and it makes it just makes it a
lot easier and a lot more and it gives
you a lot more control so yeah some of
the stuff that he demonstrated was
really good and really efficient all the
things that he demonstrated was freaking
crap basically yeah he showed a few
things he did a few things that was just
plain old stupid and not the best way to
do it again keep in mind he was making a
game that was essentially 160 by 120
pixels so he did not have to worry about
performance it actually appears a 640 by
480 because he multiplies he scales it
up by 4 by 4 times that's why it appears
so big so yeah so that's that's sort of
clearing that up yeah the other thing is
the website give you guys a sneak sneak
preview
game dev Dontrell calm it's actually
live at the moment I'm sort of I'm
incorporating a bunch of stuff into this
website I'm building it so don't worry
they'll be like drop-down lists created
winter and you guys will be able to
actually look on over here on the
website and of course they'll be source
code as you can see I'm still in the
process of developing this site and I
don't have that much time I do have one
person helping me which is awesome but
uh this stuff I did myself and yeah and
we will have the source code really
nicely formatted thanks to show source
by William Dennis
really good really good code formatter
and pull everything beautiful and nice
like that so yeah don't worry the site
will be down now because it's not ready
yet but the source code side and all
that stuff it is coming it is on its way
so don't worry about that
what else yeah I also have a Twitter and
Facebook if you guys want to stay up to
date with with what I'm doing and with
the progress on the episode or you just
want to ask me a question okay best way
Facebook page and Twitter
okay I actually check my Twitter more
than my facebook so twitter.com for such
the shona or facebook.com for so sure no
likes will be on the screen that is the
best way to reach me if you wanna ask me
a question or you actually wanna keep up
to date with what I'm doing right now
I'm actually I actually have exams going
on in school which started about a week
so I'm gonna be quite busy I'm gonna be
live-streaming or doing any of that cool
stuff yet but I'll still try and try and
make an episode for you guys once a week
okay so yeah and that's it and oh one
more thing
this this app the next episode will only
come out once this episode reaches 50
likes okay I want 50 likes on this
episode otherwise the next episode will
not come out okay that's really
important as soon as this reaches 50
likes and as soon as it hits Sunday I
will release episode 15 okay so that is
that is that my name's Archana hope you
enjoyed this weird Mouse moving I'm
pretty happy with that and I will see
you guys later goodbye